bonsoir monsieur garguy merci d'être
avec nous ils les avaient marre qui se
félicite donc vous l'a félicité on joue
aussi aujourd'hui
non parce que déjà le elisabeth bernadi
pas seulement que le chômage il est en
baisse il dit qu'on est arrivé à un
niveau qui était égal à celui d'avant la
crise or si on compare le troisième
trimestre 2000 21 par rapport au
troisième trimestre 2010 9 en fait il ya
toujours 100 103 mille chômeurs de plus
donc on n'est pas du tout arriver
alors comment elle arrive à parler de
pêche records elle parle de baisse
record passe quand elle parle que du
nombre de chômeurs qui sont inscrits à
pôle emploi en catégorie à si on prend
abc déjà en fait on se rend compte qu'il
ya pas une baisse qui est si importante
que ça en tout cas c'est pas 5 5% donc
c'est d'abord si traduit c'est un
basculement des chômeurs de la catégorie
a vers b c'est donc ça veut dire qu'il
ya une reprise de l'emploi précaire
justement ceux qui seront les plus
impactés par la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
et puis ensuite il y aura en quelque
chose de scandaleux au troisième
trimestre 2000 21 il ya eu 100 mille
radiations dans plus ou précédent
trimestre il ya cinquante mille précaire
cinquante mille chômeurs par donc on
était inscrit de force dans des
prestations qui sont totalement bidon et
donc si je fais 100 milles plus 50
milles ça fait cent cinquante mille est
la baisse du nombre de chômeurs en
catégorie à l aide de 100 millions voyez
on n'est pas bien loin donc invité il ya
pas vraiment de baisse de chômage
précarité dont on parle d'ailleurs
souvent en ce moment
la précarité elle est là elle revient
c'est ce encore une fois qu'ils sont le
plus impacté qui verront leur à la
hougue à leur allocation baissé de 10,7
boire jusqu'à 30 30% et pour faire le
lien avec ce que vous disiez a par
avance sur le pouvoir d'achat il ya un
million de travailleurs pauvres un
million de travailleurs trouvant
supplémentaires en 2000 en 2020 par
rapport à 2019 donc cette question
aujourd'hui elle est là il faut
augmenter les salaires et à la cgt nous
qu'en dit qu'il faut augmenter le
salaire pour répondre pouvoir d'achat
c'est le pouvoir d'achat tout au long de
la vie c'est dire quand on parle
d'augmentation des salaires on parle
d'augmentation du salaire direct mais
aussi indirects c'est celui qui sert à
financer l'assurance chômage c'est celui
qui sert à financer les retraites parce
que les retraités il faut augmenter
pension ils seront encore en lutte le 2
décembre il faut augmenter les
allocations des travailleurs qui sont
privés d'emploi des précaires nous
saurons en lutte le 4 décembre et puis
de manière générale il faut augmenter
les salaires de tous les travailleurs
parce qu'aujourd'hui de l'argent il y en
a les profits du cac 40 ils sont des
sermons en arrive à des records 50
milliards sur un semestre 2021 c'est
autant qu'en 2020 donc oui il faut
augmenter les salaires réduire peut-être
la part des cdd au profit des dc dc
c'est l'éternel débat c'est un petit peu
comme la hausse du smic se dit il y aura
peut-être
mais meilleur que ce soit sur la
question de l' embauche et nous c'est la
justice je suis à marseille parce que
demain il y aura une manifestation des
camarades cheminots contre la
privatisation de deux ter du train
régional en paca et il y aura avec nous
les camarades de la centrale de gardanne
qui sont en lutte contre le projet de
fermeture de leur centrale nous la cgt
ce qu'on revendique c'est de reconquérir
le contrôle des embauches c'est à dire
par des nationalisations qui sont
démocratiques où ce sont les
travailleurs qui décide et du niveau de
l'emploi et de la qualité des emplois et
y a que comme ça qu'on arrivera à
contraindre le patronat a embauché
embaucher durablement il ya aussi
peut-être l'espoir de ces secteurs qui
arrive pas à faire le plein l'hôtellerie
la restauration ça veut dire que
mécaniquement on va arriver cette hausse
des salaires quand vous appelez de vos
voeux
oui mais si je reprends encore une fois
l'exemple des des travailleurs de la
sncf des cheminots on a fait des
analyses avec la fédération et il se
trouve que la sncf elle refuse
d'embaucher elle refuse d'embaucher les
postes portant sur lesquels elle s'était
engagée à le faire elle a résulté le
résultat de ça c'est quoi le résultat
c'est que la sncf
elle embauche non pas en cdi puisque le
statut a été supprimée déjà mais en tout
cas elle embauche temps on s'est dit
elle recours à des intérimaires donc en
réalité c'est pas des offres qui sont
pourvus cd poste que les directions des
services publics et des entreprises du
privé refusent d'embaucher et c'est
parce qu'ils refusent d'embaucher qui a
un développement de la précarité donc
c'est bien sinon c'est bien signe que
les travailleurs aujourd'hui
reconquérir ce contrôle des embauches et
le moyen et ben c'est nationaliser
démocratiquement tous les secteurs qui
sont les plus importantes c'est-à-dire
ceux avec lesquels on peut embaucher
massivement des travailleurs privés
d'emploi alors dernière question puisque
c'était une autre annonce d'elisabeth
bande qui est lié évidemment on chômage
puisque elle a annoncé que les nouvelles
mesures de l'assurance-chômage entrerait
en vigueur le 1er décembre on imagine
que c'est une déception pour vous est-ce
que c'est un combat qui est perdu
c'est pas un combat qui est perdu encore
une fois on sera en manifestation le 4
décembre avec les associations de
chômeurs le mncp là c'est la pesse le
but du jeu c'est de c'est d'arriver à
construire un mouvement de masse vous
savez dans les années 90 puis dans les
années 2000 puis dans les années 2010 il
ya des mouvements de chômeurs qui ont
réussi à imposer une réponse à l'urgence
sociale et aujourd'hui on en est là
voilà aujourd'hui on en est encore là il
ya toujours plus de chômeurs il ya deux
millions de plus de chômeurs en 2020
qu'en 1998 on s'en va voilà et donc le
gouvernement non seulement il doit
annuler sa réforme mettre en place une
vraie politique de l'emploi basée sur la
réduction du temps de travail notamment
les trades de les 32 heures ces quatre
millions d'emplois supplémentaires ces
120 milliard d'euros supplémentaires
pour notre système de protection sociale
et c'est qu'avec cette mesure là où
pourra penser une indemnisation pour
tous les travailleurs qui sont ils et
d'emploi c'est qui aujourd'hui sont
indemnisés ou merci beaucoup pierre à
regardiez d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rd france